you got
this you know obviously for people who
don't know who erica banks is the busted
challenge it's probably the biggest tick
tock moment of the last year so
yeah that was just like a gift from oh
and it was an older wreck it wasn't old
but it was it's been out for like six
seven months right yeah we had to put it
out
and watch or something like that right
oh so yeah yeah nine months you know
worked it did well you know we was
getting ready to go to another song but
it's like god just paid us for for the
hard work from march to december so was
the challenge designed
or if somebody some some random tick
tocker just did it
it just randomly happened damn that's
wild you just see it just pop off that
tick tock and just do that too
look i didn't have a tick-tock nothing i
saw
when i saw those first challenges come
in i was like
so when did you know when the challenge
was popping out when did you know okay
we got something here
i knew when the first day erica posted
like six of them in a row
but she wasn't posting the right ones to
me right posting like
the ones she thought was cool i was like
[ __ ]
been posting the other one so i want to
go look for the ones that she had when i
went to go
look it was like you couldn't even find
it it was just it was over
my god you look up that damn hashtag and
it's like gosh
i can't even it's out of my hands now
tick-tock everything oh man that's crazy